hey everyone de Vol here and today we
are back for the second part of my solo
leveling series coverage as the name
says The Reawakening Arc kicks straight
back off after Jin the final member from
The Raid to remain inside survived the d
rank double dungeon the shorter but
extremely important Arc delves into more
of the world that we now find ourselves
in the weird system that Jin discovered
in the final moments of the raid is
elaborated on and our man finally starts
to make an attempt to get even stronger
before we get to that though if you are
newon here and want to watch a bunch of
similar arcs for a variety of different
series then subscribe as it really helps
out with pushing my content to a bunch
of new amazing people of course if you
want even more solo leveling then push
this video to 3,000 likes so I know you
all want the next Arc either the way sit
back and relax as we delve into The
Reawakening Arc from solo
leveline all of a sudden waking up in a
hospital beard Jen sits up and gasps
while grabbing his previously fatally
wounded chest panicked and not really
understanding what's going on he just
assumes everything that just happened
was a dream questioning if it truly was
a dream Jen turns to look outside and
sees that he is indeed in a hospital
closing the door behind them two random
guys enter Jen's room and make their way
over to him wondering who they are the
man apologizes for Starling him while
handing out his card seeing that it
reads Korean Hunter Guild inspector Jin
asks why does they came to see him after
a short chat J is blown away to find out
that he was unconscious for three entire
days he quickly asks about the current
state of jei and Mr song and is told
that they are safe however due to song
losing his arm it will most likely
impede him from his work as a hunter and
he may need to retire when it comes to
Lee ji apparently she is still being
treated in hospital due to the extreme
trauma she faced right now it's
uncertain if either of them will
continue as Hunters continuing the
expector goes on to talk about Kim and
the other two who escaped as well but
Jin refuses to hear any more info
obviously this is due to how he dis ises
the three people who chose themselves
over others and didn't even take the
time to think about what he might lose
if he dies it's revealed that like we
assumed in the last video only six of
the original 17 members made it out
alive being a hunter is an extremely
dangerous job still it's rare for a
massacre like this one to occur once the
inspectors and white tiger guilds which
is like I guess the more stronger guilds
did reach the scene everything was
completely gone instead all they found
was Jin lying at top the altar no
statues or anything that the other five
members described were there blown away
and unable to believe that it's true the
inspector explains that he has the same
feelings he truly couldn't believe it
either if it wasn't for the testimonies
of everyone else who did survive the
dungeon or if it wasn't for the deceased
who were found in that room The Guild
would have come to a completely
different explanation leaning in close
to our boy the inspector says that this
is all just a theory however they
believe that he has received the double
Awakening stunned and more or less
confused with what a double Awakening is
Jin inquires so inside of solo leveling
when someone awakens for the first time
their power level is set and it cannot
move on odd occasions though some
hunters get awakened again after the
first time throughout the last 10 years
there has been a few cases of C ranks
shooting to a rank or B or sometimes
even going all the way up through to S
rank placing a magical detector on Jen's
bedside table the inspector suspects
that if like everyone said there were
monsters with the ability to One-Shot
people normal Hunters wouldn't be able
to survive only by getting a and s-rank
Hunters with the situation have been
resolved still all the monsters ended up
disappearing to him it would just be
stupid to not suspect the possibility of
Jin wo receiving a double Awakening as
after all he was the only one left
inside sadly as the crystal finishes
calculating the strength of Jin it reads
back a power level of only 10 depressed
the inspector thinks that trash is trash
through and through like even the lowest
e- rank is still a 70 wondering what the
result was himself Jin is told it looks
as if they suspected him for absolutely
no reason watching the two guys leave
now jyn a little bummed that he didn't
surge up in strength asks himself if the
inspectors were aware of this thing
looking up at the random screen he
assumes they mustn't be able to see it
what's weirder is that his Tor or foot
has returned and the huge gash in his
chest is all back to normal it's hard to
tell what was a dream and what was
reality he guesses that maybe he should
have told the inspectors he can see this
random screen yet before he can dwell on
his thoughts any longer his banging
sister enters the room and asks if his
head wasn't hit as well cuz what the
hell is he actually doing pointing at
the sky and standing on his beard like a
ner in the room now she asks him why it
is that everyone else returned fine but
somehow he was the only one who got
injured looking at his sister raging out
at him Jen can't believe he almost left
her speaking up he asks if she's able to
see this screen in front of him not
knowing what he's on about Jen explains
it like when there's an unread mailbox
in a phone game curious if he really did
smack his head or not she tells him that
well first you'd have to open the
mailbox asking the mailbox to open the
screen in front of Jen changes to now
show the unread message welcome player
daily Quest preparing to become strong
has arrived leaving for now Jen's sister
tells him that she's going to pop off
before gapping it out with her mate
suddenly the screen starts explaining to
jyn that the system will help the
player's growth yet if he fails to obey
the systems orders there may be a
penalty for the meantime his rewards
have arrived not understanding a damn
thing yet Jin falls back and remembers
the final moments from the double
dungeon where the screen first appeared
Hing another notification jyn sees his
daily request and decides to open the
message opening a direction screen now
it shows that in order to complete the
daily Quest Jen will need to do 100
push-ups 100 curl-ups twice so so
technically 200 100 squats and a 10 km
run oh my Lord I love how similar his
quest plan is to saam's workout routine
like it's just slightly different
obviously but it's pretty much bang on
the same there was this meme I saw
yesterday when I was scripting the um
video and everything that represented
this moment perfectly and I'll try and
check it on screen but yeah it was too
good anyways anyways assuming this
entire screen thing in front of him is
just a joke Jin Le's back down thinking
that a hospitalized person doesn't have
the strength to do that instead he'll
check it after he gets some rest with
J's sleep time slowly begins taking away
until all of a sudden an alarm rings
signaling to him that he has not
completed the daily Quest due to this it
is now forcefully sending him towards
the penalty zone for an unspecified time
limit slowly waking up to the sound of
the alarm Jen's room suddenly begins
shaking and the soft Blue Beard that he
was laying on turns to Stone before then
turning into sand sitting there looking
out over the desert Plains jyn panicked
wonders where the hell he is behind him
a a mound of sand appears but he doesn't
even hear it somehow I I don't
understand how the dude does not hear
this burst of sand behind him either way
either way he assumes that this is all
just a dream right now as the shade
though from the sand Mount hits him his
head snaps back to see a poison fanged
giant centipede darting right at him
obscuring his vision which is like
actually Crazy In This Moment Like
imagine chucking up a screen in front of
like the centipede that's rushing
towards you and just being like by the
way you've got your quests to do it's
just like dude I can't see anything now
anyway anyway obscuring his vision his
quest directions pop up showing that
this penalty is one that he needs to
survive for a time limit of 4 hours
sting and having pushed himself to the
limit for the past almost 4 hours now
Jin Sprints and a hope that the ravenous
centipede behind him doesn't catch up
bringing him a level of Peace the alarm
rings signaling that he has only 7 more
seconds to go as soon as the clock hits
4:37 a.m. another signal appears
congratulating him on completing the
penalty Quest jumping forth Jin travels
through Dimensions to fall back onto the
floor of his hospital room absolutely
knackered looking up the screen changes
once again asking if he would like to
accept his reward for completing the
penalty Quest unable to make his
decision Jinn just collapses from
exhaustion moments later a nurse enters
the room and screams out in shock
wondering what in the o just happened in
this room as she yells out for someone
to give her a hand we see that Jin is
laying helpless on the floor but a bunch
of the desert sand dispersed around him
which is quite odd like did he go
through some kind of Gateway like some
forcible type Gateway what exactly
happened there do you think where he was
sent was somewhere on the planet itself
or was it like a different type of
Dimension obviously it must be a
different type of Dimension it was like
the penalty zone or whatever it was
called maybe the penalty Zone's just in
the Sahara Desert I don't know I don't
know continuing onwards either way a few
days later two nurses are seen gossiping
about Jin wo from what they've heard he
a Hunter and even though it's only been
a few days since he awoke Jinn has been
running ever since according to the
doctor this is because Hunters naturally
heal faster than normal people so light
exercise should be absolutely fine for
him looking out the window one of the
girls points out that even now he's
running since Jen first woke back up
it's been 4 days and in that time he was
able to figure out a few things firstly
this screen he can see is not an
illusion although nobody else can see it
it's clear in front of his eyes having
completed his daily Quest the rewards
tab is then showing giving JY a choice
between three different rewards choosing
status recovery our boy is suddenly
engulfed in a healing lights this magic
is somehow able to heal the fatigue
someone feels after exercising it
doesn't matter how fatigued they are it
will make the person feel as if they
have never worked out to start with on
top of that there are also stat points
and random boxed items the player can
increase any one of their stats at well
as long as you have some stat points
point the more Jen adds to his character
stats the stronger he naturally gets
when he does increase a full level it
also Buffs every stat overall slightly
he now has access to a status screen
skill screen and inventory or item
storage it's as if he's playing some
sort of game being controlled by a
random phenomenon sitting outside the
hospital on one of the benches with a
big smile on his face Jen curiously
wonders what what in the world even
happening here later that evening JY
makes his way to the reception and asks
if it's possible to take a leave for
today telling him that it's actually
fine but still needing to know where
he's headed Jen explains that he needs
to take care of some business outside of
the hospital making his way to hajung
station level three JY stands above the
staircase and Ries himself for what he
intends to do pulling out a key and
remarking that it's time to find out
what this thing does we find that Jen
got this key as a reward from one of the
boxes however this key seems slightly
different to the other ones he's used at
the hospital instead of something that
just gives him bandages this key has an
item class of e and apparently allows
the user to create something called an
instant dungeon quests status Windows
random rewards Jen assumes that this
really might be all because of that
silly old double Awakening or perhaps a
procedure towards gaining it if that's
the case then he thinks it's definitely
worth trying most would laugh if they
heard but the world's weakest hero
receiving a double Awakening seems
plausible after the previous 4 days work
feels confident and his ability to run
now so if anything does look like it's
going to become dangerous jyn's plan is
to turn and run no matter what pushing
the key forth and activating the instant
dungeon a light of swirling blue energy
appears before him expanding in size
almost immediately it opens a Gateway
into another world andlike last time Jen
walks straight forward with no
hesitation and makes his entrance into
the instant dungeon inside now an alarm
rings out and signals to him that he
into the dungeon turning around his
previous plans of fleeing inide of
danger erode away as instead of an
accessible Gateway it's showing that it
has been completely sealed off banging
on the exit to the dungeon jyn looks to
his side to watch a random female on her
phone casually walk through the sail off
Gateway confused because this is
completely different from the normal
dungeons JY thinks that surely it should
be similar to the red gates for those
confused because we don't actually get
into what a Red Gate is for like 30 more
chapters or so I'm not even there myself
yet a Red Gate differs from a normal
gate and that it seils off its entrance
once someone walked through it trapping
the humans already inside the gate and
preventing anyone else from the outside
from entering the gate this Red Gate
will also refuse to open until one of
three things happen the boss is defeated
the entire raid party is killed or a
dungeon break occurs anyways that is
just enough for now on what a like Red
Gate is I don't want to go into all of
it and spoil stuff that I don't need to
just yet anyway anyway trying to think
of a different plan of action jyn's mind
is interrupted as the alarm sounds once
more telling him that he cannot leave
until the boss is killed or he uses the
return Crystal so I guess there is kind
of like a cheat Escape way out of here
for him but I don't know if he even has
a return Crystal or it's going to be
something that he finds throughout this
instant dungeon here sweating balls and
unable to think of a way ah head Jen
feels an ominous Aura emanating from
something near by in the darkness scared
he asks himself if he can really manage
this dungeon without a passy bang so
what do you think of the second art
there extremely short and more or less
just like not not exactly like a filler
AR if you know what I mean it's not like
random content but it is kind of just a
filler Arc in between proper bigger arcs
like we had the first Big Arc where they
go in and we introduce to all the
characters and everything and then we go
into this instant dungeon Arc here which
is I guess jy's first proper Big Arc and
everything obviously ly if you have
enjoyed the video then hit that like
button and help push this video to 3,000
likes so I know that you all want the
next part of my solo leveling series if
you are new around here then subscribe
as it really helps out with pushing my
stuff to a bunch of new amazing people
and you can check out all of the other
series that I've covered either way for
now it's been your professional
degenerate deolo and I will see you all
in a bits bye